[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
parlement hebdo le magazine des temps
forts de l'actualité de la semaine à
l'assemblée nationale et au sénat avec
un mais côté thibault inox bonjour
thibault bonjour oriane est notre invité
cette semaine et guillaume garot bonjour
vous êtes à député socialiste de la
mayenne merci d'être avec nous merci à
vous et dans l'actualité parlementaire
cette semaine il ya d'abord cette loi
contre les casseurs qui a suscité de
vifs débats à l'assemblée
parmi les mesures les plus contestées
l'interdiction administrative de
manifester qualifiée de liberticide par
une partie des oppositions la loi pacte
examiné au sénat le texte déjà voté à
l'assemblée à l'automne prévoit
notamment un relèvement des seuils
sociaux et de nouvelles privatisations
les sénateurs ont émis plusieurs
réserves sur ces sujets brûlants lutte
contre la désertification médicale école
inclusive de loi socialistes ont été
adoptées jeudi à l'assemblée
un signe d'ouverture en apparence
adressée par la majorité mais les textes
ont été largement remanié voir vider de
leur substance
enfin la loi agriculture et alimentation
entre en vigueur elle prévoit une hausse
de certains prix pour mieux rémunérer
les producteurs cette méthode sera
t-elle vraiment efficace le sénat s'est
penché sur la question cette semaine et
on commence cette semaine avec la loi
anti-casseurs examiné à l'assemblée
nationale
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
annoncée par le premier ministre après
les débordements survenus dans les
manifestations des gilets jaunes le
texte est examiné cette semaine dans
l'hémicycle de l'assemblée nationale
pour le gouvernement il vise à sécuriser
les manifestations en écartant les
individus violents mais pour certains
députés cette loi enfreint la liberté
constitutionnelle de manifester et
pourrait servir à museler les opposants
résumé des débats mari la bat c'est un
difficile exercice d'équilibré pour
l'exécutif garantir la liberté de
manifester tout en s'assurant que la
sécurité est préservé jusqu'au sein même
de la majorité certains députés doutent
de son succès qui sommes nous si pour
protéger l'état de droit nous en off
habits sont les principes essentiels
effet dans les fondamentaux la puissance
publique ne serait utilisé comme
justification la protection de tous pour
affaiblir les droits et libertés
individuelles et c'est notamment
l'article deux dispositions clé du texte
qui cristallise toutes les tensions
il doit permettre au préfet de prononcer
des interdictions de manifester ce que
jusqu'ici seul un juge judiciaire
pouvait faire dans le cadre d'une
condamnation le préfet il a il ya la
possibilité aujourd'hui un dans la loi
de d'interdire purement et simplement
une manifestation moi je crois que c'est
quand même c'est mieux de faire de la
petite couture je crois de se dire qu'on
interdit administrativement à certaines
personnes qui ont colons ce que l'on
sait dangereuse que l'on sait violente
de venir à des manifestations plutôt que
d'interdire totalement la manifestation
se vient d'interdire à tous à tous
d'aller manifester car l'opposition
craint qu'un manque de critères
objectifs ne nuise à la liberté de
manifester on se croit revenu sous le
régime de vichy
mais oui mais oui mes chers collègues
oui oui oui je dis bien le régime de
vichy
mais oui il ya vous êtes présumé un par
votre attitude répressive est résistant
donc que vous en taule voilà par
l'autorité administrative
mais où sommes-nous mais réveillez vous
mes chers collègues de temps que
l'article 3 prévoit de ficher ces mêmes
personnes devant la méfiance d'une
partie de l'hémicycle
christophe castaner a tenté de rassurer
ce dont on parle c'est vraiment ce
qu'ils font l'objet
est une décision administrative dont je
rappelle qu'elle est publique est
soumise au juge qu'elle est notifiée à
l'intéressé elle est limitée dans le
temps et elle tombe mécaniquement et je
veux vraiment vous rassurer sur cela est
évidemment dans l'état d'esprit de
personnes ici de penser qu'on doit
afficher les engagés quels qu'ils soient
la proposition de loi sera votée le 5
février prochain en séance publique du
maire on l'a vu en c'est une loi
controversée une partie des députés dit
qu'elle est liberticide qu elle
contreviendrait la liberté à la liberté
de manifester c'est aussi votre avis
complètement
je considère que c'est une loi
déséquilibré je comprends tout le monde
aujourd'hui se dit qu'il faut garantir
la sécurité des manifestants d'abord il
faut le souhaiter
et puis pouvoir maintenir l'ordre public
mais dans ce qui est prévu dans cette
loi c'est pas du tout ça il ya des
dispositions qui met en cause
en effet le droit constitutionnel de
manifester est une liberté fondamentale
celle de s'exprimer de pouvoir
revendiquer de pouvoir s'exprimer dans
la rue dans l'espace public ça ça fait
partie de la démocratie donc il faut y
veiller avec beaucoup beaucoup
d'attention or qu'est ce qui se passe
dans cette loi un et je ne suis pas le
seul à le dire
regardez ce qu'a dit charles de courson
est pas un peu excessif quand même cette
comparaison avec le régime de vichy
je reprends pas forcément ces termes là
mais écouter ce que dit charles de
courson
comme d'autres députés de gauche bien
sûr mais de tous les bancs finalement
parce que y compris au sein de la
majorité
il ya des réserves extrêmement forte
parce que les garanties ne sont pas là
c'est à dire que on voit bien ce qu'il
ya dans la tête du gouvernement 1 c'est
l'idée de pouvoir isolé
des casseurs après tout on pourrait se
dire sur le papier ça peut marcher mais
en réalité on voit combien c'est
difficile de regarder on veut faire la
même chose qu'eux avec les interdictions
de stade
on voudrait copier calquer les
interdictions de manifester sur ce qui
existe pour les hooligans
sauf que pour les hooligans c'est d'une
extrême complexité de mise en oeuvre
1 il s'agit juste là d'aller au stade là
on est sur un tout autre tout autre
sujet l'espace public
la rue et donc il faut faire extrêmement
attention à la façon dont sera mis en
oeuvre
et si au final ça aboutisse et à priver
des citoyens de cette liberté de
manifester sans pour autant parvenir à
une efficacité du point de vue de
l'ordre public du point de vue de la
sécurité bien ce serait aller pour jouer
au complet ce serait un ratage complet
et bruno retailleau puisque c'est lui
qui en est à l'origine
elle serait inefficace pour lutter
contre ces casseurs lui il dit qu'il
faut protéger la sécurité des
manifestants des commerçants dis ça mais
j'ai commencé par vous et par vous à
dire ça mais est-ce que c'est comme ça
qu'on va y arriver
moi je crois pas et c'est pour ça que
nous avons fait des propositions nous
les députés socialiste dans ce débat en
disant est ce que il faut pas se poser
la question d'abord des moyens qui sont
mis à la disposition de ceux qui doivent
maintenir l'ordre
la police 1 on voit aujourd'hui combien
c'est difficile pour la police les
gendarmes et crs de maintenir l'ordre
donc il faut se poser la question des
effectifs de police et des moyens qui
sont ce qu'ils ont aujourd'hui pour
maintenir l'ordre des moyens techniques
ça c'est la première chose
2 est-ce qu'il faut pas aussi des moyens
pour renseigner pour surveiller en amont
parce que on parle de casseurs c'est pas
tous les manifestants
ce sont des gens qui profite en général
des manifestations donc il faut pouvoir
les isolés mais en amont des
manifestations donc ça pour ça il faut
qu'il soit repéré qu'il soit suivi
c'est la question de la surveillance et
puis enfin troisième chose et moi aussi
je veux le mettre dans le débat c'est la
question de ce qu'on appelle la doctrine
du maintien de l'ordre
qu'est ce que c'est aujourd'hui dans une
démocratie une grande démocratie comme
la france que le maintien de l'ordre
parce qu'on voit bien les difficultés
que c'est au quotidien je dire chaque
samedi des manifestations qui se termine
inexorablement par des violences ça ça
n'est pas tenable bien évidemment mais
on voit aussi qu'il y a des dégâts
du point de vue de ce maintien de
l'ordre lorsque il ya des gens qui
perdre un oeil
des gens qui sont blessés et donc on
peut pas considérer que tout va bien
donc là dessus il faut se poser des
questions et là dessus il faut remettre
à plat
cette doctrine du maintien de l'ordre
parce que ce qui se passe ailleurs en
allemagne m après paiement et bien
est-ce que l'utilisation des lbc
c'est la meilleure façon aujourd'hui de
maintenir les lanceurs de balles de
défense pardon est ce que c'est la
meilleure façon de maintenir l'ordre
est-ce que ça produit pas des dégâts
irréversibles alors que la question
c'est de savoir comment on ramène la
tranquillité la paix publique donc je
considère et nous considérant enfin un
amendement dans la loi qui est en
discussion actuellement à l'assemblée
que ont suspendu l'utilisation de ces
lanceurs de balles de défense
dès lors que les manifestations sont
déclarés en préfecture
ça veut dire sont soumises à des règles
qui sont celles de toutes les
manifestations
un du donnant donnant bien sûr on en
vient notre deuxième thème cette semaine
le sénat examine la loi pacte
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
adopté en octobre par l'assemblée
nationale la vaste loi pacte plan
d'action pour la croissance et la
transformation des entreprises est
examiné au sénat
la mesure qui fait le plus débat et
celle des privatisations elle sera
examiné la semaine prochaine en
attendant cette semaine sénateurs et
gouvernement se sont retrouvés sur de
nombreux points résumé signé michael
spitzberg
premier point abordé par les sénateurs
la simplification des seuils de salariés
un sujet sensible puisqu'il détermine
les obligations sociales ou des
modifications de cotisation pour les
employeurs il existe aujourd'hui 49
seuil la loi pacte propose de n'en
conserver que trois 11 50 et 250
salariés
un recul des droits pour la gauche qui a
tenté de faire supprimer cet article où
nous explique nous allons régler le
problème du chômage parce que nous
allons flexibiliser réduire les
représentations des salariés et bilan
des courses on a du chômage
de son côté la majorité de droite
sénatoriale veut aller plus loin elle a
voté le relèvement du seuil de 50 à 100
salariés mesure désapprouvée par le
gouvernement couvert paille tout y est
et autres coton tige en plastique les
entreprises françaises ont jusqu'à 2020
pour les supprimer
c'est ce que prévoit la loi et galim un
délai trop court estiment les sénateurs
pour permettre aux entreprises de
s'adapter en ligne avec le gouvernement
ils ont accordé un sursis d'un an à ces
ustensiles jusqu'au 1er janvier 2021
égal hymne contre pacte il en a aussi
été question au sujet des pesticides
ainsi son est fini de l'interdiction de
fabrication en france de produits
phytosanitaires destiné à être
commercialisé hors union européenne
objectif préserver 19 sites et 2700
emplois une vision contestée par
l'écologiste joël labbé il ya une
question d'éthique
de quel droit irions nous permettra à
nos entreprises d'aller le vendre à
l'étranger dans des pays tiers enfin les
débats risquent d'être animés la semaine
prochaine les sénateurs sont divisés sur
la privatisation d'aéroports de paris
l'état espérant récolter 9 milliards et
demi d'euros pour alimenter un fonds
destiné à financer l'innovation les
républicains soutenus par les
socialistes
ne veulent pas en entendre parler malgré
les promesses de bruno le maire
j'entends les comparaisons un peu rapide
qui sont faites avec le précédent des
autoroutes
je veux vous dire que nous ne referons
pas les mêmes erreurs pour le
gouvernement le plus dur et avis jour de
la convocation
alors guillaume garot lors de l'examen
de ce texte à l'assemblée les députés
socialistes s'étaient déjà opposés au
relèvement des seuils sociaux j'imagine
que vous n'avez pas changé d'avis
qu'elle risque que fait peser ce
relèvement selon vous la diminution des
droits des salariés mais allons plus
loin sur la philosophie de ce texte
finalement c'est un texte libéral les
mêmes dire ultra libérale dans sa
construction
dans son esprit pourquoi regarder les
dispositions il faut la regarder une
après l'autre privatisation d'atp
privatisation de la française des jeux
mais au nom de quoi pour faire de la
trésorerie pour les comptes de l'état a
déjà essayé par le passé mais est ce que
est ce que c'est la bonne solution
est ce que c'est la bonne solution de se
priver d'entreprises qui sont
stratégiques je pense évidemment à
aéroports de paris parce que c'est quand
même la porte d'entrée sur notre pays
1 et se priver de sa basse et se priver
d'un outil finalement de souveraineté
nationale donc moi je conteste
vigoureusement ces privatisations mêmes
charges
ce n'est pas une solution pour trouver
de l'argent mais à des pires amène de
l'argent
l'entreprise publique elle est bien
gérée savez vous où on nous dit que les
entreprises privées seraient mieux gérer
pas du tout regardé les comptes le
résultat deux aéroports de paris
c'est une entreprise prospère c'est
peut-être d'ailleurs pour ça que l'état
voudrait lavande mais c'est se priver de
rentrées annuelles de ressources qui
viennent chaque année alimenter le
budget de l'état donc c'est un calcul de
court terme c'est pas un calcul de long
terme et puis sur la française des jeux
excusez moi mais on sait aujourd'hui ce
que sont les risques d'addiction avec
les jeux ils ont été prouvés avéré donc
la difficulté aujourd'hui c'est que
vendre cette entreprise la loterie
nationale
quand même et bien c'est faire prendre
un risque de ce point de vue là du point
de vue de de l'addiction est là aussi se
priver de ressources
pour l'état et puis allons plus loin
vous avez parlé des seuils sociaux
on pourrait parler des chambres de
commerce on pourrait parler de beaucoup
de dispositions finalement qui disent
toujours se vend libéral doit souffler
encore toujours et toujours plus fort
est toujours plus loin
mais pour quel résultat on a vu que ces
recettes là elles ont été essayées
ailleurs dans d'autres pays sans
produire de résultats
aujourd'hui c'est sur la formation des
salariés qu'il faudrait investir c'est
dans l'investissement des petites
entreprises qu'il faudrait miser c'est
là-dessus et c'est pas du tout la
philosophie de ce texte on va parler
rapidement d'une mesure puisqu'elle vous
concerne le sénat est revenu sur
l'intérêt l'interdiction des couverts et
des pailles en plastique il a décalé
d'un an avec l'appui du gouvernement
est ce que finalement il n'a pas eu
raison est ce que ce délit n'était pas
trop court pour appliquer cette mesure
écoutez moi je suis très surpris de voir
que au sénat on laisse passer une
disposition qui remet en cause un vote
définitif d'une loi discutée l'année
passée à l'assemblée nationale moi je
constate une chose du point de vue de
l'environnement d'une point de vue de
l'écologie c'est que c'est plus du tout
la priorité de ce gouvernement
on nous a dit sur le glyphosate d'abord
qu'il fallait pas le mettre dans la loi
moi j'avais voté pour l'inscription dans
la loi de l'interdiction du glyphosate
emmanuel macron de prix dans la
république nous dit bah finalement je
suis même pas sûr de pouvoir tenir
l'engagement que j'avais pris de
l'interdire à trois ans plus deux ans
supplémentaires 5 ans donc on n'en parle
plus là on nous fait le coup maintenant
avec les couverts plastique on repousse
encore mais elle est où la volonté du
gouvernement de montrer que on change de
monde elle qu'on est dans la transition
environnementale qu'on est dans la
transition alimentaire qu'on est dans la
transition écologique
franchement s'est perdue dans les limbes
allez on va passer à notre troisième
thème de texte socialiste ont été votée
cette semaine à l'assemblée nationale
mais bien loin de leurs ambitions
initiales
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'était jeudi jour d'examen de la niche
socialiste dans l'hémicycle deux des
cinq propositions de loi du groupe ont
été adoptés une première depuis le début
de la législature alors que la majorité
rejeté d'emblée la plupart des lois
d'opposition jusqu'ici un signe
d'ouverture mais jusqu'où les textes ont
été largement réécrit au grand dam de
leurs défenseurs c'est le cas de la loi
sur la lutte contre la désertification
médicale
laszlo jalabert lutter contre la
désertification médicale
c'est l'objectif affiché par guillaume
garot le rapporteur du texte répondre à
la souffrance des territoires qui se
sentent abandonnés et répondre à
l'inquiétude et aux attentes de millions
de français
aujourd'hui parmi les mesures phares un
système de régulation appelé
conventionnement sélectif dans une zone
où l'offre de soins est élevé un médecin
libéral peut être conventionnée par
l'assurance maladie
à la condition qu'un médecin de la même
zone cesse son activité
cette convention permet au patient
d'être remboursés par la sécurité
sociale
une manière d'inciter les médecins à
s'installer dans une zone moins
attractive c'est toute l'idée de
l'article intime liddell est très simple
c'est de ne plus autoriser
l'installation d'un médecin là où les
besoins sont déjà pourvus la ministre de
la santé réplique une telle mesure
coercitive entraînerait à coup sûr la
très forte opposition des professionnels
et notamment des jeunes médecins en
formation sur les six articles de la
proposition de loi
5 avait été supprimée en commission dont
l'article 1
au grand regret des députés de
l'opposition
en commission le texte a été vidé de sa
substance ne peut que regretter qu'elle
ait été vidé de son sens lors de
l'examen en commission elle ne le sera
une nouvelle fois que dépossédé de tous
ses attributs déterminer guillaume garot
tente de réintroduire l'article 1
vous présentez votre amendement s'il
vous plaît amendement finalement rejeté
l'amendement est rejeté
c'est donc dans une version vider des
mesures contraignantes pour les médecins
que cette proposition de loi a été
adopté par l'assemblée nationale
alors guillaume garot quel bilan
tirez-vous de l'examen de cette loi
c'est le verre à moitié vide ou le verre
à moitié plein ah bin là pour le coup il
est pas simplement à moitié vide
il est quasiment vide pourquoi parce que
moi j'avais proposé des dispositions
d'urgence pour lutter contre la
désertification médicale
vous savez qu'il ya beaucoup de
territoires en france où on peine à
trouver un médecin près de chez soi que
ce soit des spécialistes ou des
généralistes
quand on observe dans d'autres
territoires dans d'autres villes
une concentration de la présence
médicale
donc la question aujourd'hui c'est
comment on garantit à chaque français la
capacité à trouver un médecin
tout près de là où ils habitent et
c'était le sens des propositions que
j'ai formulées en disant il faut pouvoir
établir un système de régulation de
l'installation de telle sorte que ce
soit beaucoup plus harmonieusement
réparties sur l'envié dissuasif et un
petit peu coercitives que vous proposiez
le déconventionnement est-ce qu'ils vont
pas mieux une méthode plutôt incitatives
mais on a fait depuis 10 ans 15 ans
toutes ces mesures incitatives comme
vous dites ça veut dire que on faisait
des propositions faisait aussi des
chèques pour que les médecins viennent
s'installer dans les territoires qui
sont les plus en souffrance
force est de constater que ça n'a pas
rempli son office que ça n'a pas
fonctionné
il ya encore beaucoup de territoires qui
manque de médecins et les inégalités
s'aggravent entre les territoires les
moins bien dotées et les mieux dotées
donc moi j'ai juste proposé qu'on
établisse pour les médecins avec les
médecins un système qui soit comparable
à ce qui existe pour les pharmaciens
aujourd'hui pour les pharmaciens pour
les kinés pour les infirmières pour les
sages-femmes
il ya ce système de régulation de
l'installation ça veut dire que on
encadre cette liberté d'installation
pour répondre à une question toute
simple c'est où est-ce que
on a besoin aujourd'hui de deux de ses
médecins c'est ça la question et moi je
dis aux médecins avec qui je veux
travailler bien sûr n'allez plus vous
installer là où les besoins de santé
sont déjà pourvus mais venez vous
installer là on a besoin de vous là où
vos patients vous attendre c'est ça le
sens de la proposition est donc à la
fois ce système de régulation mais en
même temps j'allais dire d incitation
très forte dans les territoires qui sont
aujourd'hui les plus les plus en
difficulté on concentre des moyens
publics et pour offrir aux médecins et
aux jeunes médecins en particulier des
conditions d'exercice favorable parce
qu'il nous demande d'avoir un lien avec
le plateau technique de l'hôpital par
exemple ils nous demandent la le
développement de la télémédecine pas
très bien faisons le et dont les il nous
demande aussi une meilleure organisation
de ce qu'on appelle la permanence des
soins les gardes
si on arrive à concentrer tout ça on
rendra bien sur nos territoires plus
attractif mais d'abord il faut cette
régulation de telle sorte qu'un mot de
telle sorte que l'on répartisse à un mot
sur l'aspect politique de loi socialiste
adoptèrent que c'est vrai que jusqu'ici
la majorité rejeté les lois venant de
l'opposition est ce que vous noté chez
emmanuel macron chez le gouvernement
dont la majorité en changement
d'attitude avec les parlementaires avec
notamment avec ceux de l'opposition
mais hélas ce jeudi hélas c'est un
trompe l'oeil
ça ne fonctionne pas vous savez quand on
regarde bien ce qui s'est passé jeudi à
l'assemblée
finalement la majorité elle n'écoute
qu'elle même elle n'écoute qu'elle même
on parle de la loi contre la
désertification médicale
alors elle garde le titre mais elle
enlève toutes les dispositions dedans
pour n'en garder finalement qu'un demi
article sur les cinq que j'avais
proposée même chose sur l'école
inclusive
alors il ya un petit pas en avant mais
tellement loin de ce qu'on proposait
pour mieux accueillir mieux accompagner
les enfants porteurs de handicap et puis
je vous rappelle quand même sur le
revenu de base
autre proposition que nous avons faite
motion projet ça veut dire que ça a été
d'emblée
rejeter sans même qu'on ait pu en
débattre non vous voyez est à la fois un
affichage qui se veut ouvert qui se veut
bienveillant mais la réalité c'est pas
du tout celle là et je le dis vraiment
quel dommage parce que moi j'avais
entendu dans la campagne présidentielle
et j'avais entendu les premiers mois du
quinquennat on veut travailler avec tout
le monde on est prêt à être ouverts ont
fait ces propositions ont été rejetées
allez il faut qu'on avance avec le sénat
qui examinait cette semaine qui faisait
le bilan de la loi
agriculture et alimentation adoptée au
parlement en octobre dernier la loi
agriculture et alimentation entre en
vigueur le vendredi 1er février son
objectif est de trouver un meilleur
équilibre entre producteurs et
distributeurs mauvaise nouvelle pour les
consommateurs les prix de certains
produits vont augmenter l'explication
louis dumesnil des produits du quotidien
qui remplissent nos caddies et dont les
prix vont augmenter
c'est ce que révèle le journal le
parisien en publiant une liste de 24
référence concernés par la hausse des
prix 6 3% en moyenne une conséquence
directe de la loi agriculture et
alimentation
des mesures qui visent à l'inversion de
la hiérarchie du prix au profit des
agriculteurs
une seule chose remontée des marges de
la grande distribution les grands
distributeurs et grandes surfaces vont
avoir un minimum de marche garantie par
la loi
mes romans je connais pas du tout
organisé par la loi c'est comment cet
argent est censé revenir aux
agriculteurs parmi les mesures la
fixation à 10 % du seuil de revente à
perte pour les distributeurs
une affaire de marge autrement dit un
produit qui coûte 100 euros devra être
vendu au minimum 110 euros dans la
grande distribution
si rien ne change pour les produits déjà
fortement margés
les produits qu'ils étaient peu vont
voir leur prix sensiblement augmenté des
produits jusque là soumis à une forte
concurrence et donc peu cher c'était
obligatoire à partir du 1er février
comme ça commence donc il faut qu'on
regarde ça avec calme je rappelle
d'ailleurs que nous on a fait un groupe
de suivi au sénat pour bien suivre
toutes les conséquences de la loi
oh c'est bien pour l'agriculteur que
consommateurs deuxième remarque le
pouvoir d'achat il s'analyse pas sur
quatre produits
à l'heure où le pouvoir d'achat revient
dans toutes les discussions
cette mesure censée défendre les
agriculteurs bénéficient également aux
distributeurs
benjamin griveaux a assuré qu'elle
serait observée de près par le
gouvernement
guillaume garot quelles garanties
peuvent avoir les consommateurs que les
augmentations de prix qu'ils vont subir
va bien profiter aux producteurs et non
aux distributeurs
aujourd'hui aucune aucune garantie et
j'avais mis en garde
c'était l'an passé sur les désillusions
de cette loi l'issue des états généraux
de l'alimentation
parce que en fait cette loi elle parie
sur le ruissellement des tas de façons
en disant on va permettre que
l'augmentation du seuil de revente à
perte verts reviennent finalement pour
mieux rémunérer les producteurs alors
bien sûr tout le monde est d'accord
aujourd'hui pour dire il faut que le
travail des agriculteurs soient mieux
rémunérés mais on voit les effets en
tout cas on ne voit pas aujourd'hui les
effets de ce seuil de revente à perte
parce que les consommateurs se disent
c'est moi qui vais finalement payé la
facture
or la question c'est quoi la question
c'est comment chacun des maillons de la
chaîne alimentaire entre les producteurs
les transformateurs les industriels et
puis la grande distribution prend sa
part il est évident qu'il faut d'abord
avoir en tête de rémunérer mieux les
producteurs mais qu'est-ce qui est ce
qu'ils font l'alimentation de façon
générale mais qu'est ce que fait la
grande distribution qu'elle est le geste
qu'elle fait aujourd'hui moi je ne vois
pas là heureusement il ya des contrats
qui sont signés entre certaines grandes
enseignes
certains industriels et des producteurs
mais aujourd'hui ça n'est pas la règle
générale donc moi j'attends aussi bien
sûr de la grande distribution un
comportement responsable responsable
vis-à-vis des producteurs responsables
bien sûr vis-à-vis des consommateurs
merci de votre message merci d'avoir été
avec nous cette semaine merci thibault
la semaine prochaine pour une nouvelle
semaine d'actualité parlementaire
[Musique]